hey how you doing how you doing it
awesome hey I remember you you were the
videographer the bootcamp yes sir
amazing that coaching session that you
did with grant - oh you did fantastic
great I was in the zone then so that
videos done really well has a very good
feedback on dad great that's fantastic
how you doing man how's everything over
there dude I'm doing really well things
are very different it's a really weird
time to be alive to be in business but
no I'm keeping really good that's good
man that's good to hear
hey I'm so good
great to see you you look I feel very
underdressed right now reviewing that
it's cuz you are but great to see last
night you look great
last time we met I was I was you in a
polo shirt sir yeah yeah yeah you never
know with me you know great to see you
though thanks so much for taking the
call you got it buddy appreciate you man
that's great so we I know we're not got
too much time
we're rolling we're recording right now
so I'll just give a brief introduction
and and then we can get started
who's your audience again tell me who
your audience is I've got I've got I've
got 165 thousand subscribers and then
mostly entrepreneurs real estate
investors in the in the UK mostly but we
do have we do have folks from from the
US but mostly in the United Kingdom okay
beautiful yeah so last time you came on
the channel we did really well we had
over a hundred thousand views and got a
lot of great feedback when I was on your
channel that went well people love that
oh great that was great though so yeah
so I think we'll have a good time I've
sent I've sent some questions over but
we can have a chat let's do it all right
awesome
okay so super super excited we've got
Grand Cod I'm back on the channel I'm
sure you know who he is if you don't he
is the founder of the 10x movement which
literally attracts tens of thousands of
people to his Stadium multi multi multi
multi-millionaire the lost track of his
net worth but he is in the hundreds of
millions and friend mentor to me so
grant thank you so much for coming back
on the YouTube show hey thank you thank
you for
me and thank you for everything you're
doing to help keep people inspired it's
a very interesting time to be alive
right now something that you've been
saying a lot is never waste a good
crisis or never waste a good recession
what do you mean by well what what
happens in in contractions like the one
we're experiencing now probably probably
the most severe contraction certainly in
my lifetime and maybe in the history the
last hundred years possibly right is
everybody does what they do in a
contraction not everybody not every
everybody but almost everyone goes into
non acceptance of the situation they go
to blame conspiracy theories
denial they get angry about it they lose
their job they lose their position they
lose their targets they become consumers
more than ever before
and they lose track of hey where were
you going you know and so if seven
billion people yesterday let's say seven
million people a month ago we're on
track big dreams big goals like
everybody wanted to expand a month ago
everybody had big dreams big goals
they're gonna change the world they're
gonna get their finances right they're
they're going for whatever they're
trying to go forward it's a dream house
on vacation more freedom and then boom
this thing hits they're like oh [ __ ] I
just want to go back to the way it was
so immediately there's a contraction
mental contraction yeah and and people
give up I was just having this
conversation yesterday I'm like look
I've been thinking too small the whole
time I'm telling myself this from us
with two key staff people and I should
be thinking bigger right now not smaller
how do I expand out into this not
contracts smaller into this so so the
first thing that happens is when you
when you have the you know twenty six
million people in the United States were
let go in the last four weeks I read
something today that says the UK housing
sales will get cut by 50 to 70 percent
this year yeah when that happened
all of a sudden you're like oh I just
want to sell the 12 homes I sold last
year now if I could just hold on to
those 12 no you should be thinking about
how do I expand into this because if
you're not asking the right questions
you will go in the direction of your
journey and if you're like oh I got to
pull over right now that your journey
wasn't to pull over you were on a
journey a month ago you had dreams and
goals and so when a crisis comes it's
like a speed bump flat tire you ran out
of fuel what do you do you fix you you
keep rolling you fix the tire you refuel
and you keep going and so so don't waste
this moment because we're gonna pass
this is gonna pass yeah your question is
and you're gonna get through it that's
the other thing I keep telling myself
like you're gonna get through this
everybody's gonna get through this Sam
the question is when you get through it
on the other side are you bigger and
better more confident more unstoppable
or you're smaller
contracted sports scared yeah what do
you think the potential opportunities
are like practically because a lot of my
guys are just saying I mean right now in
lockdown to it we can't leave the house
property prices are gonna go down
what what do you think practically I
mean particularly in real estate well
what are you doing right now in real
estate well you know number one you can
go out it's it's interesting to me how
many people are just so easily given up
on their freedom and just going into
agreement with the regulations that this
will be controversial right here I'm
just thinking that so so like look how
many people just said okay I'll stay in
no almost no one's challenging it
yeah I'm not staying in I mean I'm in my
studio right now I think they said I'm
not supposed to be here the police had
been here like three times this week
and I got a security guy that said yeah
tell him mr. cardones inside I'll tell
him he's not supposed to be here like
like I'm not going to give up on my
freedom okay like I'm not going to give
up on my ability to produce and to
create so if you're in residential and
you've done the residential primarily
yeah the you and I have to talk to a lot
more people
one house yeah yeah yeah I have to I
have to talk to hundreds of more people
today in order to get one deal so in the
real estate space that I'm in today
there's not a lot of deals I can do
right now because of the debt market
it's not because I'm still a buyer and
there's still a seller but the debt
market I need debt to do these deals
it's kind of seized up yeah yeah but
even that would create an opportunity
because if the debt markets not there
that means the debt market it's not
there for other people so even when I
say that I'm like oh it's not there for
them what if I can do a deal with all
cash but what if I could pull all the
cash together do a deal there's gonna be
very few people that can do that so
again the goal has to be imparted enough
number one the goal has to be imparted
enough for you to for you to get
creatively yeah good to get a creative
push because it's gonna be a little
harder to attain the target but fewer
people are going to be going for that
target now today as well yeah so the
outflow has to be higher
you got to out flow more you got to talk
to more people you got to get in front
of more people right now than ever
before you're gonna have to actually not
just service people but have something
to sell people you can't just be I just
want to talk to you to this I've gotten
more covet emails man during this time
and it all starts off the same way
during Coe bid 19 I hope your family's
like dude I didn't I'm not reading your
email because I need you to wish good
stuff for my family what can you do for
me how can you help me how can we make
money together yeah but then you say
it's gonna be a little harder you gotta
speak to little people but then you also
say we need to think bigger so well yeah
because if it's gonna be harder yeah bro
there better be some gold down there and
again if the grounds harder to pick in
there better be something underneath
that ground if there works harder the
payoff ought to be bigger yeah and when
the payoffs not big enough what happens
is people quit sure see I'm confident
this whole thing has got nothing to do
with a virus I'm confident this is
completely about wealth redistribution
whack the people that were half
committed if you were not 100% committed
to your task like Elon Musk is Elon Musk
ain't he he's not stopping anything
yeah so this is almost going to draw a
line into the Sun between the people
that are the real action takers the real
hard work was the real commit people and
those that are not really serious the
people that have partial commitments
just gave up the people that have 75
percent commitment most of them have
given up I mean you have to have be
obsessed or be average yeah you have to
be completely insane in a good way but
then they run you got to be this guy
right here yeah
ain't no buyers gonna stop him what do
you think's gonna happen with the with
the real-estate market generally
speaking over the next year or two or
even ten well what real estate mark are
you talking about I guess to start with
because I know we're in different
countries with different types of deals
the types of the toss deals that you're
doing in the in the United States what
are you thinking what are you thinking
there well we have we'll have a bill of
1.5 billion dollars but the real estate
today then we were three billion dollars
in ten years so you think you think long
term things are gonna continue rising
100% like now now if I owned a 30
million dollar house down in Miami I
don't think it's gonna be worth 30
million 10 years from now I think it's
gonna be worth less so single-family
small deals duplexes and for plexes in
America probably aren't going to be
worth more maybe they are but they're
not gonna be worth much more and they're
gonna be hard to keep they'll probably
be a lot of different owners between now
and then because they won't cash flow if
it doesn't cash flow it's gonna see the
reason I ask you what kind of real
estate is because there's so many
different kinds of real estate there's
residential single-family home there's
two units commercial for units
commercial six units eight units
commercial that we have over here
there's townhomes
there's retail there's strip centers
there's officers industrial there's
storage and then there's residential
multifamily that I bought the
multifamily off there's office buildings
offices going to get hurt
retail is going to get crushed strip
centers are going to get destroyed movie
theaters will cease to exist
Industrial will continue to expand
apartment residential will do great as
long as it's great properties great
amenities affordable the stuff that you
guys buy
over there it's gonna depend on location
yeah yeah study great if I lost my job
and I'm over leveraged on my house I
bought my house in London a year ago and
I owe to much on it because I put 3%
down when I bought it
mm-hmm you're underwater for the next
five years so now the question is gonna
be how bad do you want to live there if
you lost your job you're not gonna be
live there because you're gonna lose the
house because you're not gonna be able
make payment do you think there's gonna
be more people going into
entrepreneurship because people lose
their jobs do you think people are gonna
try and charge that cell what do you
think it's gonna generally happen to the
economy yeah yeah they could but I mean
I don't know that's a good thing now I'm
gonna work for myself okay well you
could but doesn't mean it's a good thing
yeah yeah because because look you don't
want to do this alone that that is one
thing that I would tell everybody do not
try to do this this is gonna be a
depression not a recession you know you
don't want to go this by yourself you
need a team right now so whoever you had
on your team if you didn't have a team
and you're by yourself you need a team
then you need a strong team you need
somebody with money courage and products
so I wouldn't before I go by myself
I'm gonna find somebody if I was 30
years old today I'd find somebody like
me and say hey I'm gonna go help I'm
gonna go work for grant for nothing and
add value to his company meaning revenue
I'm gonna add revenue to his company and
I'm gonna figure out how to get a piece
of his company because I add so much
value yeah yeah how do you what advice
would you give to business owners that
I've got teams right now under them and
are looking to survive through this or
to get through this I mean it's as a
businessperson myself have lots of staff
it's if there's definitely opportunities
but it's also been challenging for
people not being able to have an office
space yeah you know it's definitely it's
definitely come of its challenges it's
also given a lot of opportunities to
grow into it to adapt and to think and I
mean we've taken a lot of our training
programs online which is something that
I've been meaning to do for ages but
just have another time so it's been a
blessing in one sense and just to be
able to really just rethink and plan and
grow to do all the things that you want
to do but you don't even have time to do
but I mean what sort of advice would you
give to business owners right now with
with a staff on with tape so now you
have to be better you've got to be a
better boss in a better leader the first
thing I would suggest that people do is
find out who and what they need to cut
the cuts really important the the reason
you want to cut early is because you
want everybody that you're going to stay
with to number one know that how serious
you are and number two to properly
invest your resources in the people that
you can finish the trip with and maybe
you bring those other people that you
cut back later but you're not bringing
anybody back if you don't make the trip
yeah so if I get a flat tire what do I
do
oh that cars been so loyal to me I have
to keep it you know it's interesting how
people treat a car different than their
business you know dude look I'm on a
trip and car lets me down I'll leave the
car on the side of the road I don't care
get out of the car go get me another car
I'm not invested in that car I'm
invested in my trip you see the
difference I don't care about the tire
now when I say this people think I'm all
cold and everything but I'm committed to
the mission and I know along the way
sometimes you lose people if you're not
losing people along the way then you're
in a fairy tale you're not that's not a
real business so the first thing I would
say you need to look at who and what you
must cut yeah then you take have a
conversation with the rest of the staff
hey guys is real ladies and gentlemen
have a sermon with them
I need your product your outbound to go
higher if you can't keep your outbound
up you're going to lose your job just
like those people did we no longer sell
these products because they don't work
anymore
our pricing structure had to change you
had to you literally should have in the
last four weeks you should have changed
all your pricing all your structures all
your delivery all your offers maybe even
rename them and then the third thing you
have
to do now is you have to once you have
that conversation with your staff the
third thing is you have to daily demand
higher output from your people not not
more income production but more outbound
production is what's the difference yeah
so so I can't expect my guys to get more
deals right now or more money yeah but I
can't expect that they'll dealt that
they'll push harder yeah yeah I can't
insist that they get gold out of every
shovel yeah but I can I can demand Gus I
need you to hit the ground more yeah
what do you say about changing changing
everything around changing your pricing
structure what why is that important
right now
well because look in February before
this all happened we required a four
thousand dollar startup fee for our
online corporate program yeah I also in
my real estate I required a application
fee like all these fees as soon as this
happened I'm like oh that's off the
table startup fee four grand if you ask
for it because we paid our salespeople
and that startup fee yeah so they were
highly incentivized to get it I said
that's gone they're like oh my god
that's you can't sell you can't we have
a zero startup the right now zero yeah
and and because I don't want to lose a
deal over money right now number two is
like you got to be aggressive right now
every dollar counts here yeah and I'd
rather a customer with no margin than
they're not having a customer yeah
because in in a contraction what you
want to do is you want to go for
customer market share I'm trying to
expand into the market our real estate
for instance we're 96% rented in April
the country's 84 how am i 12 points
higher than everybody else
aggressive leadership yeah one of the
things I've noticed about the way you
run your business is you
to adapt fast when something changes
you're happy to change change something
around rather than thinking looking
upset who's looking to offend you just
yeah you don't for the business well you
see the guys that we don't actually
adapt we create the environment and let
it move toward us so I cut 42 jobs the
first two days this happened I cut our
pricing on our products the first two
days this happened I cut my salary from
every company to zero I cut every
executive salary this was before anybody
had a layoff yes I'm like I'm not I'm
not gonna wait I'm not gonna wait four
weeks when this is popular yeah you know
26 mil I cut 42 people before there was
twenty six million people laid off in
America so by the way by the way like
everybody that hates on me because I cut
people before before you start hating on
me remember you ain't buying [ __ ] yeah
exactly you didn't order anything you
cancelled your order you return the
stuff you hadn't paid for you returning
stuff you didn't need you know making
your car payment you're not making your
house payment how many people is that
cut yeah exactly
I'm paying everyone okay my mortgages I
owe a billion 1.1 billion dollars I pay
my mortgage every month yeah hey my
property taxes every month I pay my
utilities my electric bill I got 500
employees I had a guy interviewed the
other day so we didn't cut anybody I
said how many people do you have yeah 15
let's say bro I cut three times more
people than you have employed yeah and I
still have 35 times more people than you
have employed right now so you didn't
cut anybody because you don't have
enough people I heard a very popular
internet guy I haven't let go of anyone
he doesn't have any employees none he
has zero employees and he's sitting on
the internet saying I'm fortunate enough
I'm fortunate enough not to have had to
fire anyone bro he don't pay anybody
yeah so Disney Disney's cut a hundred
thousand people
Tilman 40 to cut 45 thousand people I
mean it's all over the place right but
they hire a lot of people - yeah
and you go out there what you say if
people aren't going to the hairdresser's
or what now then they're following the
hairdresser
you're firing somebody my wife reminded
me about this you know so you know we're
trying we're I've given away I've got a
charity event right here in town we
funded the entire charity event we had
we had a bunch of firefighters and
policemen in town we funded all their
meals so the restaurants by the way
giving it to the policeman's one thing
that's a nice thing at all
but buying the stuff from the restaurant
because they can't deliver in the
restaurant is keeping restaurants in
business do you think this year do you
think that was gonna be a lot of
companies that do that bankrupt 100%
what kind of what kind of companies or
what kind of entrepreneurs do you think
this year we're gonna have to end up
closing down well I read today that 14%
of restaurants in America have already
said they are permanent permanently
closed because 14% of design yeah that's
insane Wow so you know depends on how
much fundings coming from the United
States and I think over here we're
getting so much funding and I'm sure you
guys have seen some similar similar
actions take every nice cool off the
mortgage holiday payments the the
furlough it's very very similar in the
United States and in the UK not able to
pay rent
are they still paying rent we we're 96%
occupied and 95% of those people have
paid their rent collected why is that
how is it that all your tenants are
still paying rent great locations great
properties we communicate with them and
talk to them we make deals like yeah we
make good the money we paying the full
rent but the problem also also well well
know some people is that actually we
went to some people that paid 15 months
of rent in advance hmm because we
offered them certain we made offers to
reach into the future and pull money all
toward us yeah yeah yeah so you got to
be really creative right now you know
you got to be creative about how do how
could I make something work yeah what do
you think you mentioned that you think
there's a bitumen and
gender I think he said behind this this
virus talk to me a little bit about that
because that is a little bit
controversial but it's also interesting
and I think a lot of people think it
well I'm just saying we're going through
the one of the biggest wealth
redistributions in the history of
mankind so what's that going to look
like so what that means is that means
people in the middle class are basically
having money wealth taken from them yeah
and it's getting redistributed yeah
everybody in America gets a 12 on a
dollar check all right it looks like
everybody in America is gonna get a 1200
ollar check but what happens is what
happens once you get to 1200 most of
those people are gonna go spend it on
some stupid stuff hmm and this is what
the wealthy know yeah give them all the
money they want they're not gonna keep
it there's no plan to keep it there's no
plan for well there's no plan to invest
you can't get money from me because I
take my money I get rid of money and I
buy a real property with yeah the only
way to get the money for me is to take
my property from me and the only way to
take the property from me is if I don't
pay my mortgage payments and my property
taxes do you think they could ever type
problems y'all didn't the government
could ever just stop taking property off
people because it gets so bad they don't
want to do that mmm there's still homes
back from 2008 12 years ago that people
have been late on for 12 years they
haven't taken back they don't want to
take people's property back they they
can't manage what they have hell we can
t manage the roads here yeah how do you
how do you compare what's going on now
to the 2009 crash I think it's very
different but what would ya faster
faster deeper bigger wider global ugly
yeah and you mentioned there's a
depression coming like a world
depression but then you also said that
you think real estate owning your real
estate is going to ignore a lot over the
next 10 years what sort of impacts what
what do you mean when you say depression
and what kind of an impact can you see
that looking like so so 29 took two
years to really bottomed out yeah 2008
took 18 months
my real estate got me through 2008 okay
renters the renter market improved you
guys look at real estate different over
there in the UK than we do here anymore
you you mostly look at stuff to buy and
sell y'all y'all look at stuff to buy
and you buy something fix it up and sell
to somebody else I'm buying stuff to
keep it it's monopoly here yeah for me
it's rent right I just want you to land
on my place and pay me rent until I
until I break you if you just keep going
around the board dude and I got I got
the most expensive rental you know I got
stuff if I can keep it and you keep
going around the board sooner or later
you have to pay me rent then sooner or
later because in monopoly you don't get
more money you just get the money you
started with yeah and the only way to
Inc the only way to create income and
monopoly is rent yeah so if you don't
own anything or you just owned you just
own a play you own a place but you don't
have any rental income from the place
you're probably going to end up losing
your property in monopoly and in the
same thang same thing is true in life
yeah are you investing in anything else
I'll saw the greatest AG right now well
we invest in our business we invest a
lot of money in advertising and
marketing yeah we're also looking at
other companies said 10x ventures we
created early last the 2019
we've already partnered with some
companies in the healthcare industry to
help them go from from what they are to
10x that company you know we take a we
take a piece of the upside of that deal
yeah so that's business still so you've
got your real estate your business and
you know interested in anything lot
stocks gold silver or I don't do stocks
you know look I look at gold every once
in a while every time I look ago I think
about Bitcoin though so I am I am
getting actually more bullish on the
Bitcoin game oh yeah if you got a
university bit going I own some Bitcoin
because people people pay me paid me to
speak in there dear
deals in Bitcoin I never got nice oh
you've got quite a bit of Bitcoin saving
up and not not quite a bit but I mean
relatively it's it's it's it's it's a
decent amount yeah yeah yeah it goes to
a million a Bitcoin it'll be a lot yeah
yeah upside absolutely well I remember
when they were done that Bitcoin being a
hundred grand you know a BTC and I'm
like another time about it one day being
a million we printed more money in the
month of March in America then the
entire yeah
of all the Bitcoin in the world that's
incredible that we read so I'm even here
in the UK I mean we just we just printed
hundreds of billions in cash these
people that you know I'm seeing a lot of
advice at the moment saying you know
save your pennies and all that kind of
stuff and whilst I understand it to a
point because you do want to have I
think if you want to have stuff that's a
bit liquid literally but bitcoin is
pretty liquid my money's all tied up in
real estate right now I can't get my
money right now
I can't refinance because because
lingers on going out to properties so
yeah a lot of money tied up I'm okay but
I can understand why people say it's
nice how a little bit of money a little
bit of reserves and then what do you
think of all that no I don't think I
think you I think you're good the urea
liquid you think it's good to come backs
estimate long as you're not over
leveraged as long as you're not over
leveraged in your properties no no I
taught in fact last time I saw you I
think the big thing you told to me was
to be more leveraged because I had lots
of properties that were all paid off
which which works out with actually
against my own beliefs against what got
me to the point I'm at now so so but
there's people saying it's worries me
that people are talking about save money
when they're printing so much money it's
worth it like like like what are they
what are they saving pennies for pennies
don't buy anything so you know unique
even if you're even if you're saving
money you need why you saving money you
need the money to do something the money
should produce money yeah again the
problem is the problem today is that
money's not producing money dude those
properties are going to get you through
this contraction yeah look I got a guy I
know a guy he's got a bunch of low very
low end stuff and he always tried to
me to buy that stuff he called me the
dayss now I understand why you didn't
buy that stuff he's that because he's
tenants on playing rims
he's 15% collected Wow I'm 96% collected
a 95% collected yeah I mean not mine on
low-end mana like working-class but the
things the people have got to benefit
tenants there actually have kegs the the
government are just paying the rent
still so yeah really I've got some real
slum landlord friends they've got dodgy
properties dodgy tenants on benefits and
they're actually absolutely fine right
now because the the councillor just
paying their rent yeah but so was
somebody do right now I mean in this
situation
what I know I know it's a broad general
question but what's what's your main
message on your hard right now to people
in this time that I would keep I would
pay people I would look at the things
just like I said about number one find
out what and who you need to cut the
same thing I would tell a household what
in who do you need to cut from your life
is there some obligation you have that
you don't need going forward cut it yeah
financial is there people in your life
that you could afford to have it in
January and you can't afford to have
them anymore you got to cut them you got
to boss up right now you got to be you
got to do the tough thing if you want to
take care of your tribe your group your
family you have to do leadership
requires tough decisions unpopular
decisions and number one you've got to
figure out who and what to cut number
two now what are you going to go after
now that you've cut how do I start
converting liabilities to assets other
people's liabilities to my assets you
know do I make sure that my assets don't
become liabilities because they can in
these times things can get flipped yeah
yeah
so if you got a car you don't need any
more you got art you don't need any more
if you need money right you need money
to live you got to get that part handled
and then you're like okay once I get
that do I have customers that can help
me you you should be out looking how to
buy real estate right now be my
suggestion to you yeah well you should
man your portfolio right now you know if
folks are saying wait until
the crash happens wait until everything
drops and then go in what do you what do
you think about that well you're not
gonna be you're not going to be relevant
by the time that happens if you want if
you I just say this if you didn't buy
anything last year the chance of you
buying something this year are almost
nil just to none yeah if you can't buy
when things are positive how the hell
you in a gun up when things are negative
yeah first today you need more money
down your incomes going to be less the
income from the real estate way more
thousand times more uncertainty yeah
yeah it's harder to acquire you have to
have better credit and most importantly
you have to have management experienced
in this environment otherwise the lender
is gonna be like yeah you got the money
the leverage is fine we like the
property but you don't have the
experience so oh we're going to wait
until it bottoms out okay all right
whatever like you you're not gonna you
you know the great stuff there are so
many people lined up waiting for the
great stuff yeah you're gonna be like
three blocks down the list yeah that's
so you still don't have enough
confidence yeah yeah you pay the right
price to get the deep I saw this in 2009
when I was buying in 2010 I got started
and everyone was saying we're gonna wait
we're gonna wait but then suddenly 2011
where I was everything's shooting up
again and all these people that say I'm
looking away
I've now missed it cause when he goes up
he goes up fast and there's suddenly a
cube he only has to start that up a
little smidgen there's a queue of people
then yeah and none of that has happened
yet just so you know like there has not
been any there's not been any adjustment
because of what you said earlier which
is the debt market the debt markets
frozen so you're not having transactions
right now that's the worst thing that
can happen right now there's no
transactions mmm
so the other thing the other thing
that's going to delay this cycle is that
all the money that the government's are
funding so gives people longer to not
pay yeah so this cycle you know probably
will not be anything to buy for probably
six six to eight months mm-hmm so which
is what you would be looking for right
now is stuff where guys have to sell it
because they're in a fund and they had
some agreement with their
Bester's that this was the year that
we're gonna sell and they can't sell it
can't be any later than it's in their
documents it's in their names done so
creamy with people that have to sell
right now they're gonna be - just like a
massive hair yeah that's not because of
their finances but because of the
agreement they had with the money the
investors yeah that makes a lot of sense
I mean that definitely makes a lot of
sense do you what do you think as well
and then we'll wrap up kind of on this
question rarely but in terms of the news
and stuff there's just so much
negativity going on and and that's just
with worldwide about everything how do
you maintain a positive opportunistic
upbeat attitude during times like this
you know look I struggle with it just
like everybody else this is not an easy
time it's scary
uncertainties everywhere bad news
everywhere the thing the thing that I
continue to do is I was just telling
Jared few minutes ago we're just
thinking too small
hmm you know let's take it to small and
so like I'm like where am I going
where am i trying to get to because I
could be seduced into a beach right now
pretty easily yeah I'm gonna lay on the
beach and I don't need to do all this
you know and then I'm like wait a minute
there's no beaches open either like
there's the Caribbean shut down down st.
Bart's to shut down there's everywhere
you go there's problems right so there's
no getting away from that where am I
going yet so so I think the thing I need
to wake up every morning hey I'm still
going for 10 billion dollars for the
real estate maybe 20 yeah why not 30 so
how do I do that
got to stay relevant got to keep paying
my bills got to take care of my
properties got to show people that I
know how to get through tough [ __ ] you
can't expand if you if you fold every
hand you can't win if you followed every
hand so you got to play the cards you
got right now it's tough and then but I
have to keep making contacts with people
that can actually benefit me in 21 22 23
mmm I got I got to be a
to be a beacon of a possibility and
potential and future so so that when we
go when things start lifting off and we
can do deals I'm relevant to the
conversation and I gotta cross my
fingers dude and just believe that I
gotta believe that things are gonna get
better like if you just study a little
bit of history we've survived everything
yeah we have World War One World War two
look what London's been through over the
years man so we're gonna get through
this the question is for your audience
you know when you when you get through
this because you're getting through this
there's no not getting through this and
you will get through this what are you
gonna be like on the other side bigger
better more stoppable more confident
well you've learned a lot about yourself
about your better not just learn about
yourself but like you're better because
of this event you have to lean into this
thing say I'm gonna make myself better
right now yeah or or are you gonna end
up smaller shrunk up depressed beat up
it's really your choice you go to prison
you know yeah we've all seen the prison
show where the guy goes to prison and he
finally gets his house he finally gets
his [ __ ] together in prison gets in the
best shape of his life starts reading
becomes a room you know becomes
religious or spiritual because of it he
decided man I'm gonna make this time I'm
gonna make this jail time into that
pivotal moment of my life where I become
the person I'm intended to be yeah
that's great
that's really good well I really
appreciate your time again look forward
to seeing you again same hopefully in
Miami in the sunshine next time
appreciate you brother we're look we're
doing it have been here in July right
we'll be the first people to do live
events in the United States August
September October we have you mean this
year July 100%